bomberos y equipos de rescate y buscan
entre los restos calcinados de lo que
fue un animado local para la vida
nocturna según la policía camboyana unas
400 personas se encontraron en el Hotel
Casino gran diamon City cuando se
incendió el miércoles por la noche
es uno de los varios establecimientos de
la ciudad de paipet un popular destino
de vacaciones en la frontera con
Tailandia para visitantes de países
asiáticos que prohíben el juego
el incidente ha movilizado a personas de
ambos países ya que cientos de militares
policías y equipos de rescate se unieron
en la búsqueda de supervivientes
los muertos que conocemos Ahora son
tailandeses como muestran las
identificaciones ahora están esperando a
ser identificados
estas imágenes muestran a los equipos de
rescate tailandeses entrando en una
habitación llena de humo en la planta 15
muchos tailandeses se encontraban en el
hotel en ese momento y las ambulancias
cruzaron la frontera para trasladar a
algunos de los heridos a hospitales de
la provincia de zacao
estoy triste y creo que si la ayuda
llegará más rápido si el rescate llegará
más rápido no habría tantas pérdidas las
autoridades siguen intentando determinar
Cómo se originó el incendio en la región
preocupa desde hace tiempo la laxitud de
las normas sanitarias y de seguridad en
los establecimientos nocturnos